and now we have a special
treat hold on to your yarmulkes okay
from east to west you know they're the
best
getting you in the zone for your
milestone
is that cute please welcome gavilta
fresh and
dr dreidel
is there a daniel rosenbloom
[Music]
when you see black people at a bar
mitzvah it's very exciting it's like a
scary ride
and the kids just love it right now we
are the number one ball slash bob mitch
for potty motivators in all of nassau
county i mean you got
the bot missiles yeah yeah always to men
you know all of them coming through like
a velda kaya
with the recycled dragon and i mean the
hutzpah these guys
with their fakakta shtick it's it's a
real shonda on what it's supposed to be
simca yeah yeah it's supposed to be a
sim card
you just really can't put a price on the
look on your child's face when they see
a black person for the first time
oh it's just magical really
is he getting back up or what we are not
technically chosen we're chosen by the
chosen
which is kind of better than being just
the chosen that's right
it's less responsibility jews are like
black people but we were black people
before
there were black people um although i
guess that's not true they were just in
a different
part of the world they're all black
people coming to get me help
[Music]
[Applause]
find it spiritually intoxicating
find it culturally fascinating and we
find it monetarily
exhilarating when we say sarah you say
schwartzman sarah
sarah yeah
i mean the fact that we're willing to
put forth the extra time is what sets us
apart
i mean how often is a 13 year old gonna
hear their own name
we learn that name we rehearse it
[Applause]
judaism can be a very somber religion
that's right you know something we
learned along the way is that the word
ghetto means something very different to
these people
to tell you the truth i was a little
nervous about the whole thing and no not
because they were black but because you
never really know what those kind of
people are gonna do
if we can add some fun some life some
color
to a jewish person's life when they're
still young
they might not grow up and run away from
black people when they say maybe they
won't
or uh fire people so willy-nilly
when they're older
we provide a service to these people
we motivate parties so that's what we do
that's what we do we motivate parties
you